[Music]
mitchell is with us in south lake tahoe
california
hey mitchell what's up
hello dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help
um so i've been following your show for
about a year now and
um
i have a tip based job and i make
minimum wage but
with the tips
it's hard to kind of follow all of all
the rules and stuff um i'm trying to
figure out what i should do like my next
step you know what i mean cool so you're
not making minimum wage you're making
good money serving right
yeah it's actually uh i'm a limo driver
i'm a chauffeur okay what do you make
what's your total you're making in a
week
tips and tips and pay
i would say total
probably 800 a week and on average
good for you good for you yeah okay
here's the way you need to do a budget
and all the rules do work you just got
to use them a little differently okay
right what i want you to do is i want
you to make a list and you could do it
you could start doing it with a yellow
pad you can use the every dollar app and
modify it and use it this way as well
but let's just do it on a yellow pad
right now in your mind just so you can
follow the principle okay just get a
yellow pad out in your head you see it
in your head right now
i do yeah okay now make a list down that
page of every single thing you need to
do with money or want to do with money
this month and just start putting dollar
amounts beside all of it all the way
down that page in your mind you don't
have to do them all right now but that's
what you're going to do
then once you get that list made i want
you to look at that list and say if i
only make enough money to buy one thing
because this month sucks what is the
most important thing on this page i'll
help you with that it's food
put a number one beside food and put a
dollar amount beside it
okay i've always cut rent so i think
that's wrong yeah well rent's going to
be a little bit down the way but you'll
get there in a minute okay number two is
utilities
number three is rent
because you got to keep the lights on
and then pay the rent if you pay the
rent don't have any lights you you get
cold
right so we're gonna but you got enough
easy to do these three things anyway so
you put dollar amounts beside you go
food utilities shelter you have a car
payment
um no i actually
after i started watching i got debt free
so i was pretty happy wonderful way to
go way to go okay so now you just keep
going down the list and say okay what's
the next most important thing and put a
number beside what's the next most
important thing put a number beside it
what's the next most important thing and
you put a number beside it so you got 1
through 36 or whatever it is down the
page in order of importance in order of
priority are you following me
i do yeah and they all have a dollar
amount beside them so when you get some
money from a paycheck or a tip
you look at you look at the list and
wherever you are on the list you start
there and work your way down
and so the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to set some money aside
in an envelope for food we write food on
the envelope we set that in the kitchen
drawer and we don't buy anything from
that envelope except food and we don't
buy any food except from that envelope
and that keeps you right on budget then
the next thing you're going to do is
you're going to pay your electric bill
the next money you get you're going to
go ahead and pay your rent the next
money you get you're going to do the
next thing and the next money you get
you're going to do the next thing and
every so often you're going to draw
lines through the ones above that you've
done and you can rewrite the list a
matter of fact you could do it once a
week and rewrite the list because it
might change a little bit from week to
week
it does yeah every week yeah not only
your income no because we don't know how
far down the list you're going to go
because we don't know exactly what your
tips are going to be you could have a
1200 a week or you could have a 600 a
week we don't know right
exactly yeah yeah so we don't know how
far down the list you're going to get
this week but you do have a list and
every dollar that you're going to make
is already spent because the list needs
to be longer than you're going to make
right that makes sense but let's say
let's say you're in the third week of
this and the rent's already paid and the
lights are already paid and the food's
already in the cabinets
when you rewrite the list you don't have
to put those on next week next week's
gonna be a week where you get to do some
stuff down in there like paying off debt
or putting some money in savings or
increasing your generosity or something
like that
and so but you've got a prioritized list
and john this is how sharon and i lived
with that literal yellow pad there was
no internet there was no apps we had a
yellow pad like that and because i was
in the real estate business when i first
started doing these principles and i
would have a month where i would make
twenty thousand dollars and i'd have a
month where i made zero yeah
and so
we were taking some of that money and
setting it for the next month if we had
a big month
and we're but we're going through
food if we make just a little bit of
money we eat
first thing we do okay you know kids got
to eat got babies it's a formula and
diapers and you know we got to go the
grocery store what's the next thing
we're going to do we keep the lights on
and the heat on yeah the cool the air
conditioner on
and what's the next thing we're going to
do we're going to keep the house
you know and you can usually get your
basic life done
and then you start to relax a little bit
emotionally because your your survival
is now guaranteed you're you're
sustainable right
and but that priority that those yellow
pads
um
sharon was telling one of our friends at
dinner the other night that she said and
we kept another yellow pad of goals that
we want to knock off big things we want
to do we want to do this we want to do
this we want to do this and we had that
prioritized
and uh so as we got a little extra money
you know like we're driving a piece of
crap car we had to get her a better car
and so that's a goal that's over on
another yellow pad and we would just
jump back and forth between the yellow
pads but it was all about listing
and prioritization and then it gives you
something to work for that's right and
intentionality he can if he's got
something he's trying to hit he can take
an extra shift that's right he can take
that ride that he doesn't want to take
after midnight which is gross a lot of
times you know limo you know and so uh
or he could take up you know a sunday
morning early to the airport that he
didn't want to get up at four but he can
go take that if he's trying to hit a
goal because he can get that extra tip
and if you don't have anything to live
for if you don't have anything to work
towards you just because it's not listed
out you just go why do i work you know
and you spin your wheels out but you'll
increase your income doing this but you
also have a few weeks to look at
oh i may not hit my food i need to come
up with something and it doesn't
surprise you week of or day off right
you can see it coming yeah
because there is a plan that's right and
the point is you're still
spending every dollar on paper on
purpose before the month begins
don't wait till you get the check people
to try to figure out what you're going
to do with the check
always have it already spent
already assigned before it comes to you
to something before it comes to you
always do that the rest of your life and
i even do that with high net worth
people
high income earners like i was with an
nfl guy the days getting a
multi-million dollar bonus coming
and um had a good year and uh he's like
what do i do with this and i said i
don't know but let's go ahead and do it
before you get it yeah you know put a
percentage on it okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna live on ten percent of it and have
a great life
you know and i'm gonna give
a extra ten percent and i'm gonna invest
and whatever it is you get you need to
give those dollars an assignment before
you get them
because what happens is you will spend
that check that's coming oh man like 10x
so fast in your head yeah you spend it
10 times yeah you act like it's 10 times
more money than it is 5 to 10 times more
money it's not as much money as your
little brain thinks it is until you put
it on paper